in the opening scene we are introduced
to Danny Roark a detective from the
Austin Police Department who is
currently attending a therapy session
during the session he reflects on the
traumatic event of his seven-year-old
daughter named Minnie being abducted
which ultimately led to the breakdown of
his marriage it is revealed that he was
at a park watching his daughter play
when he got distracted for a few seconds
if only he didn't have such a thing for
pinwheels upon turning back around she
discovered that many had disappeared the
person responsible for the abduction has
been apprehended but was not charged as
he was deemed mentally unstable
following the therapy session Danny is
picked up by his co-worker Nix who
informs him that they have received an
anonymous tip-off call regarding an
upcoming bank heist targeting a specific
safe deposit box according to next the
recent string of bank robberies has
involved the same bank but at different
branches however the strange thing about
this robbery is that the thief is
specific targeting a safety deposit box
that does not contain any money maybe it
has pinwheels upon their arrival outside
the bank Danny and Nix enter a police
van to maintain surveillance on people
both inside and outside the building
during their Stakeout they observe a
mysterious man named Lev de la Reign who
seems to possess an uncanny ability to
easily hypnotize people the power is
demonstrated when he hypnotizes a woman
causing her to feel so hot that she
removes her shirt on the street and
people say hypnotism is for nerds
delauren then hypnotizes some Bank
employees and even police officers who
obediently follow his commands as he
enters the bank sensing something amidst
and he quickly exits the van and gets
into the bank pretending to open a bank
account he promptly makes his way to the
deposit box room and unlocks the
targeted safe to his surprise he
discovers a photograph of many along
with the message find the left de
Lorraine written on it I can already
tell this movie is going to have a bad
twist meanwhile delaurain stands at the
counter line when the bank security
guard suddenly erupt into chaos at the
same time he hypnotizes a bank employee
who then heads into the safety deposit
room to retrieve the targeted box Danny
who is already present in the room aims
his gun at the employee and demands that
she frees however she disregards his
order and continues her search for the
desired box the hypnotized guards also
enter the room and shoot Dany causing
him to collapse but fortunately his
bulletproof vest Shields him from harm
following this incident both the
employee and the security guards exit
the bank and board a van intending to
escape simultaneously the woman who had
experienced intense heat earlier stands
in the middle of the road this results
in several accidents including one
involving the van carrying the bank
employee and the security guards shortly
after deloraine retrieves the safety
deposit box from the deceased Bank
employee and plants a timed bomb right
before making his Escape Dany
accompanied by two of his Juniors spots
deloraine and chases after him they
eventually managed to Corner him at a
rooftop as the two detectives approached
to handcuff him deloraine suddenly uses
his hypnotic abilities and manipulates
them into firing their weapons on each
other Dany seems really bent out of
shape about this deloraine then leaps
off the building swiftly Vanishing from
sight after the chaos ends NYX arrives
at the scene and informs Dany that all
the witnesses have no recollection of
the events due to the effects of
hypnosis Danny who is convinced that the
heist is somehow connected to his
daughter's disappearance embarks on his
own investigation on the same night NYX
contacts him and relays the results of a
trace conducted on the previous tip-off
call wasting no time Dany proceeds to
the specified location and finds a
therapy facility owned by a fortune
teller named Diana Cruz he tells her
about the purpose of his visit and the
two start a conversation but when Dany
mentions the name de la Reign she
becomes scared and orders him to leave
the place immediately unbeknownst to
them deloraine lurks outside the
facility he sneaks up behind a biker and
hypnotizes him causing him to ride a
motorcycle through Diana's window the
man says deloraine will not stop before
committing the unthinkable in a weird
and unconvincing way following the
incident Danny takes Diana into
protective custody and proceeds to
question her the latter discloses that
both the bank heist and the recent
incident are the results of deloraine
exploiting his supernatural abilities
she explains that deloraine is a
hypnotist with the capability to
manipulate and control minds using a
psychic bandwidth Danny asks how she
knows so much about hypnotics to which
she replies that she is also one of them
according to Diana both she and
deloraine underwent training in a covert
government hypnosis division designed to
harness mind control however deloraine
became the most powerful disciple and
ultimately turned to evil oh my God it's
Star Wars for Street magicians and Ben
Affleck is pissed deloraine is now
looking to gain control over the whole
country hearing all of this NYX who is
also present there simply Chuckles like
a good proxy for the audience he doesn't
believe in all of this and claims that
she's joking in response Diana
hypnotizes NYX compelling him to step
outside for fresh air after this she
reveals that Dany possesses a strong
immunity to mind control perhaps because
he is severely depressed these days
Diana knows this because she tried to
hypnotize him earlier but was
unsuccessful on the other hand deloraine
appears outside the police station and
hypnotizes next he then orders the poor
guy to attack his friends as NYX enters
the investigation room Diana quickly
realizes that something is wrong with
him so she suggests that they run away
she claims that NYX will not regain
Consciousness until he fulfills his
assigned task despite Diana's advice
Danny tries to stop his friend and even
handcuffs him however NYX continues his
desperate attempts to reach for his gun
ignoring the pain given by the handcuffs
when the situation gets out of hand
Diana grabs nyx's gun and shoots him in
the head killing him on the spot
fortunately Danny is a sociopath and
this barely seems to affect him at all
the news of nyx's untimely demise
quickly spreads through television
broadcasts and Danny and Diana are shown
as the perpetrators with no options left
Diana proposes that they travel to
Mexico where she knows someone capable
of thwarting delrane Dany is skeptical
about the idea but he has no choice but
to agree in the next scene the duo is
seen at a local coffee shop When a
sheriff enters he instantly recognizes
them but before he can react Diana
manages to hypnotize him at the same
time delrene contacts Diana through the
Sheriff's walkie-talkie freaking her out
our protagonists attempt to flee but
right then delrane arrives with two
hypnotized police officers just when it
appears as if Danny and Diana are about
to be apprehended the hypnotized Sheriff
from earlier shows up in the nick of
time and saves them later during their
journey to Mexico Diana reveals to Danny
that he possesses a psychic block that
makes it more challenging for hypnotists
to control him probably because his ass
is so depressed the only one who can
overcome this barrier is Del reign as
the two approach Mexico City they come
across a police patrol but then again
Diana skillfully uses her abilities to
maneuver past them ultimately they reach
their destination Jeremiah an old friend
of Diana's from their days in the
division as they engage in conversation
Jeremiah unveils the truth that delrane
is in search of domino a potent weapon
developed by the division with the power
to manipulate any hypnotist in the world
it turns out that the Domino project was
divided into several parts and stored in
safe deposit boxes across multiple Banks
according to Jeremiah if Delrin finds
all the parts of it there will be no
stopping him this movie meant he then
unexpectedly asks for the picture of
Minnie which Dany had acquired from the
bank earlier this raises suspicion in
Diana's mind and it is soon confirmed
when Jeremiah morphs into Del reign
turns out he had been using his
abilities to transform himself into a
totally different person acting quickly
Danny and Diana flee the scene with
delrane giving Chase through an
intricately constructed hypnotic
environment many officers and random
citizens also join in the chase not long
after our protagonists find themselves
cornered but just as they are about to
be captured Dany Taps into his own
reserve of hypnotic power and takes
control of the police officers directing
them to apprehend Del Reign instead he
just thought about the pinwheels and
Rain Man to that after the danger
is averted Dany is filled with confusion
unable to understand what he just did
Diana is also equally perplexed so she
suggests that they seek assistance from
River a secret hacker who is once her
friend within the division later they
arrive at his Hideout and explain their
predicament to him River agrees to help
them and uses his hacking expertise to
delve deep into dany's Data shockingly
he uncovers a startling revelation
wife Vivian is actually a member of the
same hypnosis division just like Diana
as the three are talking Danny receives
a call from delrane who attempts to
hypnotize him over the phone urging him
to execute Diana however Danny somehow
manages to resist the hypnotic influence
and just hangs up on his ass later while
River and Diana are asleep Danny
personally checks the database and
learns something shocking his daughter
Minnie is actually Domino the dangerous
weapon and Diana is none other than his
wife Vivian what did I tell you about
the twists with this the entire room
around him begins to unravel showing
that all the previous events were mere
hypnotic constructs it becomes clear
that Dany had been under hypnosis
throughout his entire Journey at this
point Diana walks out and reminds him
that he was the one who took their
daughter away motivated by the desire to
Shield her from the Allure of hypnotic
Realms soon after the anyway up in a
large room populated by division agents
all of whom he has seen throughout the
constructed story including NYX and
delrane scared Danny runs out of the
premises only to stumble upon the props
and materials that had been used to
create the illusion of reality realizing
that they were mere scenarios here it is
revealed that dany's memories had been
wiped erasing any recollection of
Minnie's whereabouts so the division had
subjected him to these constructed
experiences in an attempt to trigger his
memories afterwards Danny has once again
put through the same hypnotic construct
reliving the therapy session and the
bank heist just as before the events
unfold smoothly mirroring the beginning
of the film however as Dany reaches the
point of entering the bank he Taps into
his own power and breaks free from the
hypnotic spell escaping from the
clutches of the division in this moment
both delrane and Diana realize that the
phrase in the photo find Lev Del Reign
does not refer to a person but rather to
Deer Valley Lane which turns out to be
the location of a ranch where Danny's
foster parents have been hiding many for
all those three years holy piss after
driving for a while Danny arrives at his
parents house and experiences a
heartwarming reunion with his now grown
daughter Minnie however their joyous
moment doesn't last long as delrane and
his team members arrive armed with
weapons they immediately shoot Danny's
parents cruelly finishing them off in
the next scene Danny and Minnie walk out
of the house making Diana emotional as
she is seeing her daughter after such a
long separation meanwhile the division
surrounds the ranch but many uses her
overpowering hypnotic abilities to make
all of them kill each other she then
forces delrane to commit the unthinkable
Minnie the Pooh dishing at that sweet
honey finally it becomes evident that
Dany and Diana were the most powerful
members of the division in the past one
day they discovered that their daughter
many had inherited even greater strength
than themselves when the division found
out about this they devised a plan to
exploit her as a powerful weapon however
Dany and Diana vehemently opposed this
notion instead they chose to protect
their daughter by hiding her in the home
of Danny's foster parents while
intentionally erasing their own memories
for many safety the photograph
discovered by Danny in the safety
deposit box was actually his own
creation serving as a means to remember
the whereabouts of his daughter so that
one day he could look for her defeating
the whole purpose of the plan and get
his foster parents capped back in the
present many assists her mother in
regaining her lost memories it is
revealed that Dany and Diana patiently
waited more than three years for many to
fully develop her powers to a level
where she could single-handedly defeat
the entire division with their ultimate
goal now achieved the family reunites
and decides to live happily ever after
however in a surprising final scene it
is unveiled that delrane managed to
survive Drive the earlier shootout as he
appears to have cunningly disguised
himself as Danny's Foster father what so
what subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching